two three Chili's YouTube midlifecrisis
in the morning hello welcome back it's
day number three and I'm feeling
slightly less stressed out so that's a
good thing fortunately it seems that
YouTube midlife crisis week is sort of
working like therapy for me they don't
want to talk about that stuff today
because I actually have a plan for this
video oh yeah as of this month I've been
making YouTube videos for five years
which is almost a quarter of my entire
existence on this planet which is a
little bit scary but also very cool and
as I'm sort of the equivalent of like a
Youtube old fogey now I have lots of
opinions about what I think is the right
way to do this vlogging stuff and so
today I would like to present unto you
all my personal youtube rules the things
that work for me specifically and it
might not be for everyone but I like
them rule number one I don't ever tell
people to like or comment or subscribe
or any of that stuff unless I actually
have a decent reason to what I'm sitting
here in this little box on YouTube you
are being nice enough to give me a bit
of your time and attention and so one of
the things that I try and stay aware of
is you know not to waste that time there
are basically two ways that I can ask
you to like and comment and subscribe
and all of that kind of stuff the first
way is for me just to stand here and say
please like and comment and subscribe
and all of that stuff but the other way
is just for me to make the best videos
that I possibly can and assume that if
you do genuinely like it you will like
it or if you have something to say that
you will comment and if you do want to
subscribe then you will and that I don't
need to tell you to do that number two I
don't like to give the people who watch
me here on the Internet any kind of
group name or title one of my personal
favourite youtubers is wheezy waiter
I've mentioned him on this channel
before I've watched him ears I still
really like him I think he's great so
one of the things that Craig does in his
videos is he refers to his audience as
beardlovers and although I've been
watching him for years I always find it
weird when he calls me beardlovers
because I don't love beards I just like
his videos it's not the kind of thing
that hinders my enjoyment of him at all
it's just never been a title that I've
been able to connect with the way that I
think it goes the majority of the time
when someone's watching a video blog
myself included is that there is one
person sitting in front of their
computer watching another person so two
people and that is something that I try
and stay aware of when I'm making these
videos I don't want to refer to you as a
group of people as the cool like is or
whatever because hey you are not a
group of people you are just one person
and be I don't want to assume that you
are a fan of what I do you might be you
might not I just think that fan as a
word is quite loaded and I get emails
from people saying that they don't
consider themselves like a fan but they
do like my videos and so I want to
include them and all people when I'm
making these videos by just talking to
you you a real person on the other side
of this camera Jesus I have like seven
more rules I don't think I'm going to be
able to get through all of these let's
just see what we can do okay number
three first and foremost I try my best
to make these videos for myself and if
other people like them as well then
that's really lovely but that's not the
goal making youtube videos used to just
be my hobby but now it is also my job
and that can come with some problems I
do worry about this becoming you know
too much of a job and me losing my
interest in it and so the way that I
rectify that is by making it as fun as I
possibly can for myself because if I'm
not having fun doing this then I'm just
gonna stop he just wouldn't be seeing me
anymore I would not be here and so that
is why my personal satisfaction is at
the top of my list because if I was just
here trying to pander to some specific
audience or whatever then I would just
stop because it would not be fun and if
anything that makes me more plays that
you've decided to watch this because
you're not just watching something I've
made you're watching something that I
like and that's the best thing maybe
it's just taking me a bit longer to film
this video than normal but I feel like
I've been talking for way too long I
mean I would love to stand here for ten
minutes and tell you my opinions about
YouTube but I also have four more videos
to make this week so probably these have
a break cool beans thanks watching bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool